welcome to hannity and tonight coming up
a bombshell new report on joe biden's
deep involvement in his son's illicit
business deals with communist china plus
we're going to bring you shocking newly
released video from the criminal
investigation into alec baldwin on the
set with the onset shooting of that left
that one woman dead uh and the great one
mark levin is here tonight he's going to
explain
why he's back on twitter and how the big
tech world is experiencing an earthquake
and how america's left is absolutely
melting down for freedom of speech
amazing but first tonight it is official
twitter is under new ownership soon elon
musk will take the reins of the social
media giant and is vowing to improve the
platform he says by making algorithms
open source to increase trust defeating
the spam bots authenticating all humans
and must also emphasize free speech it's
the bedrock of a functioning democracy
and twitter is the digital town square
now naturally democrats their allies in
the media mob
why are they freaking out i thought
liberals believed in freedom of speech
apparently not in fact we're now on day
two of what can only be described as a
full-fledged public meltdown without any
evidence at all whatsoever some on the
left are calling elon musk a racist and
one msdnc anchor actually worried that a
political candidate could now be banned
or throttled on twitter that that could
be happened that we can ban a politician
on twitter
pause for a second now i guess it's
perfectly fine that twitter and facebook
and instagram twitter banned president
trump and many other conservative voices
and now they feel all of a sudden now
all they feel
under elon musk that politicians might
be banned the same people that will
perfectly fine that hunter
and his laptop that story was suppressed
the same people that didn't care one
lick that donald trump was cancelled on
twitter who the same people that lied to
you the american people for years about
trump russia collusion that never
happened
wow you don't say all of a sudden while
banning people on twitter is a bad thing
really where have you people been take a
look
if you own all of twitter or facebook or
what have you
you don't have to explain yourself you
don't even have to be transparent you
could secretly ban
one party's candidate or all of its
candidates
all of its nominees or you could just
secretly turn down the reach of their
stuff and turn up the reach of something
else and the rest of us might not even
find out about it till after the
election at a time when authoritarians
insurrectionists and rogue petro states
are weaponizing disinformation online in
a way they've never done so before
elon musk says he is buying twitter to
save free speech online
and by what he means by that is he wants
to push back on efforts to moderate
content on these websites so when elon
musk says wow this is about free speech
it seems to me that it's about free
speech of straight
white men
okay these are the very same people that
didn't say a single word when
conservatives were banned they were
shadow banned
their voices were being silenced they
never uttered a single phrase of support
for freedom of speech but they're
fearful it might happen to them now
ironically the vitriol is even worse on
twitter one hyperparanoid msdnc
personality actually calling elon musk a
bad faith actor with a history of racial
animus now owns messages to and from
black people that were intended to be
private or quasi-private
another little-known blue checkmark
tweeted quote musk will amplify racists
and bigots and misinformation he's a bad
faith actor and with his distorted views
on freedom of speech and censorship
uh
this is like we live in an alternate
universe here now meanwhile high paid
twitter employees based in san francisco
they're reportedly very distraught they
probably need counseling tonight and too
in shock to even speak at this time oh
the vapors they can't believe it now by
the way elon musk is obviously much
smarter than me doesn't really need
advice from sean hannity but elon you
might hear about this if you do if i
were you i'd really seriously consider
firing most if not all of these
employees and bring in your own team
because i suspect a lot of them will be
trying to undermine you and your success
the entire way now according to politico
twitter's top lawyer openly cried during
a meeting about the takeover i'd fire
him too
democrats and journalists and woke tech
employees they have lost all touch with
reality the truth clearly clearly means
nothing to them they really do hate free
speech they had no problem silencing and
canceling conservatives they feared the
free exchange of ideas
they yearned to be coddled
and after growing up in liberal areas
and going to liberal schools and
learning under liberal professors and
then working among liberal colleagues
and spending time on liberal twitter
where liberal moderators cultivate a
safe little liberal space while many on
the left have literally never apparently
been exposed to different perspectives
or opinions because they did cancel
donald trump and other conservatives now
they're very very afraid they might
cancel a liberal they didn't seem to
mind louis farrakhan's nonstop racism
and hatred on twitter or the stream of
lies from iran's ayatollah or the
communist propaganda from the chinese
government and their officials but now
the left is freaking out because they
might get exposed to conservative
opinions that they disagree with oh
obviously a fate worse than death
apparently one new york times editorial
board member is now deeply worried that
twitter will become a scary place and
far more toxic
it's pretty toxic towards people like me
right now just take a look at my
timeline anyway as elon musk tweeted
earlier today the extreme antibody
reaction from those who fear free speech
says it all he's right elon musk said i
hope all of my critics stay on twitter
so you can learn what free speech is all
about he's inviting you to attack him on
the very site he owns now elon musk is
not the only person facing the left's
hysteria look what's happened in the
florida governor ron desantis he has
drawn their ire does it quite
effectively now he is an effective
governor a republican governor not
afraid to fight back we saw that during
covent we saw it obviously with the uh
parents rights act that he recently
passed so naturally according to msdnc's
well pretty hateful and dishonest
conspiracy theorist well ron desantis is
trying to stop black people from voting
really take a look
buckle up buttercup because today baby
maga signed a bill that allows him to
create his own private police force that
is tasked with pursuing alleged election
law violations just lovely
the big lie will now have its own
battalion of goons
i wonder who they'll go after first i
think you can guess so he's taken away
um black representation as you've said
he's taken away the ability of african
americans to vote and he passed this
police force that you know is going to
be sick on black floridians to
intimidate them out of being able to
vote
okay calm down not true none of it on
twitter joey reid also accused ron
desantis of child abuse that's how
desperate people are why because he was
pictured on stage with african-american
children who wanted to be part of a
historic bill signing now joy reed is
simply lying there's no other way to put
it like many on the left who fear free
speech and transparency those that love
cancer culture only of conservative well
to them transparency and lying just
happens to be a way of life denying
transparency now they depend on lies
smear slander besmirchment to win
elections that's the democrat and the
left's playbook every two four years and
now it's pretty much every day and by
the way become more popular and they
become more virtuous and now at least on
twitter it appears they're about to face
the music and the very thing that they
were silent about is now
potentially going to impact then but in
reality i don't think it will i actually
believe elon musk is going to have a
free and open exchange of ideas ideals
and opinions now of course they won't be
banned they're not going to be throttled
but as former president trump said once
truth is a force of nature hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else